reuben it seems like you like to have
long takes
and and hold the camera on the actor
uh and really
give the viewer a sense of the
uncomfortability in the room or whatever
what's your reasoning for that
um
i i think it's interesting to bring out
an example when you talk about this
because
uh what i wanted to highlight yeah and i
wanted i have been aiming for in almost
every of my films is to put the very
dramatic events next to trivialities uh
and i think because then then you can
really show the the humor that is
existing in even dramatic events so
for the and
like the avalanche scene
the last sentence that is said before
the avalanches trigger is isn't there
any parmesan cheese and then
then we have this dramatic event taking
place and when you have the real time
aspect of filming
and you put those two just next to each
other i think you're highlighting
something different than than cutting
between different
camera angles
you